there's only a few things I really care
about in life my body my pan my right
my family my church my boys my girls my
body my pad my ride my family my church
my boys my girls my poor body pad ride
family sure choice girl
that's her little er she's a dime oh
this feels more than a dime for oh my
god were you in love with this girl
already so I've seen this barrel oh my
god what's the name what's the name
why'd you say yes to me I'm just gonna
have to wait to find out
all right I got time be cute I like you
oh yeah yeah listen you want to know the
truth you're the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen in my life
you like movies i watch too many movies
the pretty woman the pretty man mean
they drive off into the sunset
everyone knows his fake I love you he's
like that yeah great but they watch it
like it's real life baby what are you
doing I was just reading you man no you
weren't
she caught me watching points that's it
right Oh how do you watch all the stupid
movies are you watch so me too dad boy
doll eyes this right John they give a
once the movie thank you for wars 4.2
so it's only a few things that really
care about in life I don't know if I
really want to watch some kids look what
you did if you want to lose yourself you
have to lose yourself in another person
it's a two-way thing I thought you would
say friendly and maybe stop me try
something new